okay I've had a couple of these calls in
the last little while so I got stopping
addresses for a second Dave the rents in
our area are so high so much higher that
I can buy a house so much cheaper a
month not true you're not comparing
apples to apples
at least over a period of time it cannot
be true economically and let me walk you
through why because it's a basic concept
but you know again this is the thing
where we get scope creep a thing where
we get justifying rationalizing buying
the house when you're not ready to buy a
house or buying a house you can't afford
or buy a house in a situation where you
shouldn't I loved homeownership I've
always believed long-term owning home is
one of the best plans you can have
long-term but you need to do it in a
wise way so the home is a blessing and
not a curse
and the stupidity that's out there in
the culture including in some of the
wonky think tanks it's like all home
ownership is down Americans you know the
the wealth inequality gap is widening
it's difficult to buy a home yeah that's
all true but broke people when they buy
a home aren't blessed it makes them
broker that's why they call them
mortgage brokers and if a whole bunch of
Piro people buy a house at one time you
could bundle it and sell it on the hedge
fund and later on is a regular mortgage
block and actually crash the whole
economy back to 2008 does anybody
remember so it's not a good policy
decision not a good macroeconomic
decision to force people into buying
homes or to encourage people to buy
homes when they are broke now once
you're ready to buy a home though and
you're looking at rinse and you say
rents are you know $1,500 a month but I
can buy this house for $800 a month that
is just not true long term and here's
why it could be true for a moment in a
boomtown where something's going on like
the struck oil okay I mean you get in
one of these boom towns you could have
that happen but
eventually a supply demand curve and
economics will take effect and here's
why
landlords want to have renters and when
there is an abundance of renters willing
to pay ridiculous prices what they do is
they start building rental property or
buying property and turning it into
rental property and so if there's a
house on the market on the street and an
individual can buy that house and it's
$800 a month or an investor can buy that
house and it's $800 a month and he can
rent it for 15 and there's an abundance
of renters out there is the reason the
price has driven up there's a shortage
versus the demand anytime demand is
higher than supply prices go up okay
when there's a shortage on something
that's when prices go up in other words
okay but what happens is the shortage
corrects itself very quickly because
those of us that are investors we want
to tap into this hot rental market and
so we go buy a bunch of property and
turn it into rental property or build a
bunch of property and turn it into
rental property which raises the supply
back up thus the shortage goes away so
over time rents are not going to be
double prices of a house price of a
monthly payment on a house because
investors that are willing to borrow
money or willing to pay cash like I am
will buy enough rental property to take
advantage of the great rates of return
that overpriced rent an overpriced
rental market will do and it will cause
the rental to come down or the value of
the houses to go up and they so rent
always approximates slightly above
payments it always does
over time and so when you call me up and
say oh I can buy fifty percent of what I
can rent no you can't you're looking
you're not comparing apples to apples in
the neighborhoods
you can if you can buy you know because
investors would have already gobbled
that house up and doubled their money
that's the point and that doesn't weigh
with the shortage which causes the
economics to balance out now again there
might be a six month period of time
where that is not true but long term in
Missouri long term in Boise
long term in Abilene that's what happens
at a probably you know if there is a bit
of a jump for one reason or another very
quickly it will even out and most of the
time it's already pretty even rent is
going to be slightly more than payments
on average because investors require
renters to pay enough rent so they can
pay their payment or so they can get a
rate of return on the cash they have
tied up like in my case I'm not going to
tie up money at four percent return in a
piece of rental property I got to get
more rent out of it than that because I
can make more than that on my money
doing something else and so that's going
to drive rental rates that's what we're
talking about here and so these are
always going to approximate each other
now if you find rent that or if you find
a house payments slightly less than
rental that would be normal and it is
not cheaper in that case so let's say
you have a $1,500 rental rate and you
have a $1,200 payment now that would
probably be fairly accurate rent is
always going to be a little bit more
than payment but you're not paying when
you're renting to put roofs on and fix
heating and air and fix broken hot water
heaters you're not paying the increases
in insurance and increases in property
taxes that come along until I renew your
lease and then I'm going to bump up
enough to cover that but that's the
difference homeownership in a given year
might be more expensive for you as a
consumer than renting depending on the
repair bill that you end up having and
so there is no economic no mathematical
excuse for buying versus renting until
you're ready
on the short-term on the long-term
owning is always better than renting so
you want to get yourself in a position
that you own as you build wealth and as
you head towards retirement that's going
to assist you and with a paid for home
and in building wealth but it does not
assist you when you buy a home and you
rationalize your little butt off just
because you got house fever and your
little friends are out there buying
houses and your little family members
are whining at you over Thanksgiving
dinner about they bought a house and you
and bought a house yet why didn't you
bought a house because I'm freaking
broke and I'm not gonna be broke soon
because I'm on a budget I'm gonna get my
debt paid off I'm gonna get my emergency
fund in place so when I buy a house with
a good down payment on no more than a 15
year fixed rate on no more than 1/4 of
my take-home pay as a payment then I'm
gonna buy a house and the house is gonna
be a blessing not a curse I want you to
own your house I don't want to own you
and too many people rationalize their
butts off they got student loans at
Browns long we think they're a pet they
got two car fleeces sitting in the
driveway
they got Master Card they've discovered
bondage and American distress all the
money comes in and all the money comes
out and they've strapped themselves to a
house on a thirty year adjustable rate
mortgage and it's some of the lowest
interest rates in my lifetime and I'm
almost 60 years old if it's the lowest
interest rates in 60 years where the
flip do you think it's going to adjust
up dummy up not down I mean where are
you going from two point nine one point
nine I mean really is this your set of
assumptions on which you justified
buying an adjustable rate mortgage
that's dumber than a grubworm in a box
of rocks that's stupid
you're gonna get killed don't do that
but we gotta have that one with a
Jacuzzi in the skylight and I don't feel
safe three streets over and we come up
with all this crap that we used to
justify and all this peer pressure the
most expensive purchase you're ever
gonna make for most people which is
their house don't do that do it right so
that your home becomes a safe haven and
not a point of stress on your finances
on your marriage and in your belly